encore les votes aux États-Unis pour les
élections mimanda mais une chose est
sûre il n'y a pas eu de raz-de-marée
républicain de marie-rouge et Joe Biden
c'est en principe de le souligner
lorsqu'il a pris la parole il y a
environ une heure les démocrates qui ont
quand même réussi à sauver les meubles
en partie on va regarder les derniers
résultats à ce moment-ci avec Raphaël
Jacob et Elisabeth Valley bonsoir à vous
deux bonsoir alors regardons d'abord la
composition de la chambre de
représentants en ce moment bon avant on
se républicaine mais encore quand une
cinquantaine de courses qui sont pas
encore terminées démocrates qui ont
encaissé quand même moins de pertes
qu'attendues puis au Sénat c'est au
cours de coude présentement 48 49
impossible de dire vraiment là qui en
prendra le contrôle Raphaël quand vous
regardez les résultats qu'on a en ce
moment qu'est-ce que ça vous dit samedi
prudence et patience d'abord et avant
tout pour ce qui est du Sénat on y
reviendra peut-être pour ce qui est la
chambre des
même si on n'a pas tous les votes qui
sont dépouillés on ne sait pas
exactement quelle sera la composition
finale ce serait à ce stati je crois
estomacant que les républicains aient
plus de 223 225 sages on risque d'être
dans ces eaux là donc au final dans le
meilleur des cas les républicains auront
fait un gain de peut-être 10 à la limite
une douzaine de sièges une courte
majorité alors non seulement une courte
majorité mais un très très faible gain
net et dans un contexte historique
écoutez on est dans les eaux à peu près
là des sœurs subies par le Parti
démocrate en 1962 alors que de Genève
Kennedy était président et le parti
républicain en 90 lorsque George bouge
pas était Président je mentionne ces
deux présidents là parce que à ces
moments de leur président ils étaient
tous les deux nettement plus populaires
que les présentements monsieur Biden
donc les démocrates ont littéralement
pardonnez-moi l'expression
surperformer à la Chambre des
Représentants il y a quelque chose qui
est carrément historique Elisabeth on
n'a pas voulu à ce moment-là dire à
on rejette les deux dernières années où
on a voulu envoyer un message de rejet
plutôt à Donald Trump comment vous voyez
ça c'est une bonne question je pense
qu'il n'y a pas d'explication
monolitique il y a beaucoup de facteurs
qui sont entrés dans cette équation
électorale ce qui explique d'ailleurs
que les sondeurs et failli à la tâche
parce qu'il y a quand même eu quelques
erreurs de prédiction qui ont été faites
on est très loin de la vague rouge que
certains avaient prédit et que que
certains réseaux avaient prédit
également donc le il y a beaucoup
d'éléments qui sont rentrés en ligne de
compte probablement que les candidats
trumpistes ont inquiété dans certains
cas donc on fait sortir ce vote qui est
un vote pro-démocratique en quelque
sorte que certains républicains qui ont
de l'allure eux ont été ont été élus de
manière par un électorat qui se censé
être rassuré d'avoir à faire à des à des
candidats qui justement s'inscrivaient
en faux par rapport à Trump et puis la
question de l'avortement a fait
également sortir un autre pan de
l'électorat ce sont beaucoup de facteurs
je pense qui ont été à l'oeuvre et
beaucoup de beaucoup d'éléments qui sont
aussi bien liés à l'économie qu'au
conservatisme social qui que l'on voyait
monter tout au long de cette campagne
électorale et il y a eu une
participation très très importante des
électeurs tout à fait et c'est vraiment
pour les élections mi-manda c'est
quelque chose d'important je pense que
ce que Raphaël soulignait est vraiment
le point que l'on doit que l'on doit
tenir compte c'est que on est dans une
espèce d'anomalie historique ou un
président dont la cote de popularité est
extraordinairement basse performe aussi
bien que des présidents très populaires
dont le dernier qui était en temps de
guerre donc en temps de paix c'est
quelque chose d'inédit au cours des 40
dernières années c'est vraiment
indicateur peut-être d'éléments dont on
doit tenir compte désormais lorsqu'on
analyse les élections américaines ben
c'est ça qui a essayé de comprendre quel
est le message Raphaël que les électeurs
ont voulu envoyer finalement
mais quels électeurs parce que elles
habitent et moi on a eu la chance de
faire la soirée électorale ensemble à
RDI et avant ce matin donc un cas hier
soir je n'avais pas vu ce qui est pour
moi peut-être la donner la plus
stupéfiante c'est à dire que malgré le
taux d'approbation qui selon les
sondages menés aux urnes à l'échelle
nationale hier pour Monsieur Biden
serait dans les 43 44 % 44 % pour être
plus précis dès l'approbation à
55%. les électeurs indépendants donc ce
qu'on pourrait qualifier si on veut en
simplifiant là du centre de l'électorat
américain ceux qui sont pas affiliés à
un des deux parties majeures aurait voté
en pluralité pour les candidats
démocrates donc les candidats démocrates
auraient été non seulement en mesure
d'aller chercher la clairement le noyau
dure la base du Parti démocrate mais une
pluralité des électeurs plus modérés des
électeurs indépendants alors que
Monsieur Baden encore une fois auprès de
ses électeurs-là depuis des mois
semblant avant tout l'approbation dans
les 30 35 38 %. donc on était capable de
se distancier clairement presque d'un
océan à l'autre dans le cas démocrate
d'un président qui est plus clair il y a
quelque chose encore une fois de
vraiment remarquable dans tout ça et
quel sera l'impact maintenant pour Joe
Biden pour les deux prochaines années
pour gouverner le pays par exemple
Elisabeth c'est la réponse à laquelle
nous ne sommes pas en mesure de répondre
à l'heure actuelle et probablement qu'on
ne sera pas en mesure de répondre à
cette question avant le mois de décembre
si le sénateur de l'élection sénatoriale
de Géorgie va dans un deuxième tour ce
qui est le cas si aucun des deux
candidats n'obtient 50% des voix plus
une et donc ça ça se déroulera début
décembre donc c'est si on en est à une
voix près et bien la réponse à la
question que vous venez de poser
littéralement sera donné en décembre
lorsque l'on sera s'il te calborde se
situe le Sénat et c'est vraiment un
élément important parce que le Sénat
joue un rôle clé dans le portrait
constitutionnel américain il approuve
les traités ils approuvent les juges
c'est un élément vraiment important
ils font une partie ils sont le pendant
de la Chambre des Représentants donc
peuvent mettre un terme à des projets de
loi qui n'auraient pas d'allure le
président aussi par le droit de veto
mais quand même donc le cette clé du
Sénat est déterminante aujourd'hui pour
déterminer la marge de manœuvre Cora Joe
Biden pour les deux prochaines années
dans le contexte actuel et vous parlez
du droit de veto si par exemple il y a
une
réforme que Joe Biden veut passer
Raphaël et qu'il doit utiliser son droit
de véto à ce moment-là quand on parle
d'une courte majorité républicaine
qu'est-ce que ça peut avoir comme impact
sur son droit de veto bah écoutez 60
passages je pense qu'il faut réaliser
que ça va dépendre de ce qui va se
passer au Sénat d'abord avant tout et
pour ce qui est de savoir quand on va
savoir ce qui se passe au Sénat il y a
une nuance à ajouter c'est à dire que
c'est très possible qu'on doit attendre
quatre semaines pour le deuxième tour en
Géorgie il va y en avoir un deuxième
tour ça c'est je crois c'est c'est réglé
la question c'est de savoir est-ce qu'on
va le savoir avant ça parce que vous
regardez on ne Vada bénévada
présentement ça rentre dans tous les
détails granulaires là à une course qui
est extraordinaire candidat républicain
et à peu près 2,7% en avance sauf qu'il
reste des dizaines et des dizaines de
milliers de votes postaux qui sont
disproportionnellement démocrate à
dépouiller la question c'est de savoir
une fois que tout ça ça va être compté
est-ce que l'avance va avoir été comblée
ou le retard pardon par la candidate
démocrate la démocrate sortante
sénatrice cortaz masto ce qu'elle va
pouvoir combler cet écart là et le
battre et si c'est le cas écoutez le
deuxième tour en Géorgie n'aura pas
d'importance parce que les démocrates
auront déjà gagné une nouvelle majorité
au Sénat alors que si le républicain
l'emporte et bien là ça se réglera pour
ce qui se contrôle du Sénat engagé dans
400 donc encore quelques courses à
surveiller qui peuvent être vraiment
déterminantes ça peut aller jusqu'au 6
décembre comme vous l'avez mentionné
tous les deux là pour ce qui est de la
Géorgie qu'est-ce que les résultats
représentent maintenant pour Donald
Trump pour le trumpisme il a fait une
déclaration qui a fait énormément sur
scier Donald Trump et on va l'écouter
déclaration de Donald Trump est-ce que
ces élections veulent dire pour lui
le fait que run the centis est été réélu
au Lama en Floride et le gouverneur de
Floride est visiblement le plus grand
compétiteur de Donald Trump à l'heure
actuelle le fait que lui est vraiment
gagné en ces temps distancier de de
Donald Trump d'une part et le fait que
un certain nombre de candidats
trumpistes eux ont bu le bouillon est
indicateur que le trumpisme est toxique
y compris pour le parti républicain qui
pourrait alors être tenté de regarder du
côté de quelqu'un d'autre donc du côté
de de sentis donc c'est une à l'heure
actuelle Trump qui n'en est pas à sa
première défaite parce que quand on y
pense bien 2018-2020 2022 en fait c'est
peut-être là le grand perdant en chef
mais donc essaye essaye de transformer
perdre du terrain mais essaye de
préempter en quelque sorte ça en disant
non non mais si si je perds s'ils
perdent ça dépend de ma s'il gagne c'est
vraiment grâce à moi en fait c'est un
argumentaire trumpien comme on en a vu
tellement le problème ou le l'enjeu
c'est que ça pourrait le très bien lui
réussir parce que dans 4 semaines de
maintenant si jamais par hasard la
Géorgie tombée du côté républicain et
bien il dira regarder c'est moi qui est
fait basculer tout à fait et la mémoire
la mémoire politique est courte donc on
aura peut-être oublié ce qui s'était
passé à oui mais round of Suns j'imagine
Raphaël va vouloir vraiment maximiser
cette grosse victoire victoire éclatante
qu'il a eu en Floride là à ce moment-là
on s'attendait on en parlait la semaine
dernière ensemble à ce que Donald Trump
annonce officiellement sa candidature la
semaine prochaine pour les élections
2024 parce qu'il va toujours vouloir le
faire pense à ce moment-ci vous savez
que le peu de temps qu'il nous reste
ensemble carène je laisserai peut-être
simplement avec une image l'ancienne
avocat de Donald Trump dans Meghan avait
un surnom pour pour l'ex-président
républicain parce qu'ils connaissait
certaines de ces sortes d'humeur et le
surnommait King
on doit avoir un don dans le champ en
privé qui est en mode King Kong
présentement parce que clairement en
voyant la victoire de Monsieur Dos
Santos le gouverneur sortant d'affleurer
de voir une décision monumentale à
prendre et immensément de pression
assurément qui va être mis sur ses
épaules par tout le courant au sein du
parti républicain qui est enfin
peut-être prête après 6 ans pour pas
dire 7 à sequaliser derrière une
alternative singulière pour tonnerre
tête à Donald Trump je vous dis pas que
ça va se produire mais il y a une chance
que ça se produise comme on en a pas vu
depuis l'arrivée littéralement sur la
scène politique de Monsieur Trump en
2015 on ne s'ennuie jamais on était Unis
en suivant cette politique donc à suivre
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler Raphaël
Jacob et isabeth Valley merci infiniment
de votre présence ce soir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI